even though we think we understand what
we're seeing and hearing and many of the
scenes in the trailer for the rise of
Skywalker there's a pretty good chance
the final film might present something
very different from the conclusions
we've drawn the footage may be edited a
certain way or digitally altered or just
presented in a context that hides the
bigger picture with that in mind it's
time to talk about all the possibilities
contained in this footage and some of
the ways in which we could be deceived
by it the trailer for the rise of
Skywalker begins with an unforgettable
sequence in which Rey stands alone on a
desert planet and waits as a first-order
TIE fighter approaches when it enters
her path
she ignites her lightsaber then runs
until she's between its wings and leaps
the implication here is that she's
preparing to cut the ship in two with
her blade aimed right for the cockpit
and the even deeper implication is that
kylo Ren is the pilot of the ship that
may indeed be the case but look closely
at that ship and it becomes clear that
it's not one we've necessarily seen
before in the last Jedi kylo flew at AI
silencer with an all black paint job red
tinted windows and a very angular
cockpit this ship looks more like a
traditional Thai interceptor with a
brighter paint job around the rounded
more typical looking Thai cockpit design
we also never get a look at who's at the
controls we get a shot of some hands but
nothing that definitively reveals the
pilots identity is this an epic rematch
between Rey and Ren or just a marketing
fake out in Star Wars the last Jedi kylo
Ren smashes his helmet to pieces in a
fit of rage after Supreme Leader Snoke
like a true disciple of the pickup
artist nags him for wearing it
the loss of the helmet is about kylos
anger yes
but also seems to be part of his growing
philosophy of letting the past die
despite this the rise of Skywalker
teaser trailer shows that same helmet
being pieced back together by a pair of
mysteriously furry hands when we see
kylo Ren in the teaser though he's not
wearing the helmet he's charging into
battle with his head uncovered burying
opponents with his lightsaber now it's
obviously possible that the helmet
simply isn't reforged yet when that
scene takes place but it's also possible
that kylo isn't even the one who decides
the helmet needs to be put back together
unless his hands got super hairy under
those gloves there have been two deaths
stars in the Star Wars galaxy so far
both destroyed by the rebellion at
different locations
the first exploded near Yavin for thanks
to Luke Skywalker's careful aim and the
second was destroyed over the forest
moon of Endor by Lando Calrissian wedge
antilles and the rebel fleet in the rise
of Skywalker teaser we see rey finn poe
Chewbacca c-3po bb-8 and do looking out
over what seems to be a fragment of a
destroyed Death Star the image is
immediately followed by the sound of
Emperor Palpatine laughing which would
suggest the Death Star wreckage is from
the second station the one Palpatine
died on that's not necessarily the case
though Javan for is a planet full of
jungles while the forest moon of Endor
is full of well forests the footage we
see features a vast sea and sparse
grassy cliffs
maybe this wreckage landed on another
planet entirely this could even be a
third or fourth Death Star we never saw
in the movies at all the remnants of
some kind of abandoned super weapon
experiment whatever the case we can't
necessarily assume we know which Death
Star that is and that's exciting fans
around the world are excited about the
potential return of Emperor Palpatine
signified by his fantastic laugh at the
end of the trailer admit it no matter
how you feel about Star Wars these days
everyone is excited for more of this guy
yeah yeah
that said we just don't know how exactly
he might actually return a Palpatine
clone would allow him to manifest in a
physical form though it wouldn't really
be him anymore in the strictest sense
while a force ghost would allow him to
retain all of his memories and past
deeds with less ability to interact with
the physical world all of that said it's
possible the Emperor isn't actually
returning at all for all the hype
surrounding his resurgence it's possible
ray or kylo or both could simply see him
in a vision or that our heroes might
find an old hologram recording of him
somewhere in those Death Star ruins now
let's talk about that title
the rise of Skywalker if we begin with
the argument that the simplest
explanation is often the best then that
means we got a discuss Ben solo aka kylo
Ren much of the last Jedi was devoted to
examining his mission to finish his
grandfather's work of wiping out the
Jedi and to raise belief that she could
redeem kylo Ren if Ben really is
redeemed in this film then it's possible
that he might once more take the true
name of his grandfather and his uncle
who tried to save him and become Ben
Skywalker that's the simplest route to
an explanation for the title but it also
feels pretty unlikely a movie made by JJ
mystery-box Abrams in which the key
villain converts to the side of good
again isn't going to Telegraph that
twist right there in the title so we
should maintain our skepticism with
regard to this theory if we set aside
the kylo Ren is redeemed version of the
titles interpretation that naturally
leads us to turn to Rey the desert
scavenger turned force user whose
origins remain shrouded in mystery the
force awakens teased that we would
eventually learn Rey's origin even
throwing in a big force vision the first
time she touched Luke Skywalker's old
lightsaber this prompted waves of
speculation that Rey was a secret
Skywalker or perhaps the secret solo or
Kenobi the last Jedi seemed to shove
those theories aside when kylo Ren told
ray her parents were just junk traders
who sold her off to a slaver on jakku
but many fans believe kylo was lying so
now we're facing a film literally called
the rise of Skywalker and Rey's action
heavy moments in the trailer certainly
make her look like a person on the rise
is she the Skywalker the title
- again it feels too easy for a film
this shrouded in secrecy to give
something like that away upfront and
that brings us to the most popular
theory to rise in the wake of the new
movies title reveal according to the
internet hive mind now that we've seen
the last Jedi it's time for the galaxy's
force users to call themselves something
new Skywalker's the first two Star Wars
trilogies ended with films that featured
the words Jedi and Sith in their
respective titles each concluding with
the return or The Revenge of a group of
force users the last Jedi featured
numerous references to Luke Skywalker's
belief that the Jedi were too
self-righteous to be preserved and that
the order should end
Yoda confirmed that belief by destroying
the Great Tree at the heart of the first
Jedi Temple
so the Jedi are indeed gone in some form
so what if rey chooses a new direction
and uses the name of her mentor as a
label what if Skywalker is not a person
but a group of people now that's a rise
that might be pretty interesting indeed
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
star wars are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]